[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a japanese action thriller film
called battle royale spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the japanese employment system alongside
its government has collapsed students
see no benefit in going to school and
getting a degree which causes the number
of high school dropouts to skyrocket
most dropouts indulge in one or the
other criminal activities adults lose
trust in youngsters since most of them
have turned into criminals in times of
emergency the only way to save society
is by eliminating the high schoolers
before they get a chance to ruin the
country altogether in a desperate
attempt the government passes a reform
act called the battle royale according
to the act every year a class of high
school students are put against each
other in a fight to the death this way
only one out of hundreds of students
survives which further benefits society
the movie begins as a reporter
frantically announces the return of a
schoolgirl to mainland japan she has
returned after winning a deadly game of
battle royale one might think that a
teenage girl who is made to kill her
friends for survival might have gone
through hell but when the camera zooms
into her face she stares at us with a
sinister smile then we are introduced to
the protagonist of the film shuya he is
a kid in middle school traumatized by
his mother's abandonment and his
father's death because of personal
problems he hardly ever attends school
his friend noriko however is a kind and
polite girl she goes to the class and is
the only one present because of the
student's bad behavior their teacher
kitano has been distressed lately as he
is leaving the class a student stabs him
in the leg just for the fun of it after
recovering from the injury kitana
resigns from his post and never looks
back at the students again one year
after the incident shuya and noriko are
in high school their class is going on
an educational trip everything goes well
for the first half of the ride a few
hours later shuya wakes up to see that
all of his friends are unconscious the
bus driver and conductor are wearing gas
masks when they notice he is awake the
conductor knocks him out in the
following scene he wakes up again and
finds himself in a classroom with all
his classmates they gain consciousness
and look around trying to figure out
what is going on they also have a
strange device attached to their necks
that doesn't come off suddenly several
helicopters land outside and an army of
soldiers comes out alongside them is
kitano the teacher who the children used
to disrespect until he resigned he tells
a confused class that they have been
recruited to take part in battle royale
two outsider students named shogo and
kazuo are also in the room who are
supposed to take part with them the two
have already played with their
classmates and are more experienced than
the others kitano plays a video to
explain how the game works but a girl
whispers to her friends in the middle of
it the teacher throws a knife at her and
scores a direct hit on her forehead
killing her the students panic and
finally realize the severity of the
situation they watch the video
attentively after that it turns out that
they are on a remote island with no way
to escape the students will be given a
bag full of supplies that they will have
to use for their protection or to attack
others the callers on their neck are
tracking devices and microphones if they
try to escape or do anything against the
rules it will explode a guy panics and
refuses to listen to the presentation
because of the disruption kitano presses
a button that causes an explosion
resulting in the student's death if more
than one student is left by the end of
three days all their callers will
explode leaving no winner the thought of
dying brutally like their friends scares
everyone and motivates them to play the
game following that the soldiers bring
them a supply bag that contains the same
four survival products but the weapons
on all of them are different they hand
them the bags one after another before
sending them outside the newcomers shogo
and kazuo are also given a random bag
but shogo insists that he get a new one
because his is too light the two are
ready to kill anyone to become the
winners having already killed people
they were close to shuya finally gets
his head in the game and rushes outside
with his bag suddenly one of his
classmates who had run out earlier
emerges from the forest when she gets
closer shuya notices the arrow sticking
out of her throat it is clear that
people have already started killing each
other noriko also comes outside but
before the two can decide their next
move a guy with a crossbow attacks them
they run away leaving the guy to fight
another one of their classmates the
couple then ends up in a cave where
shuya checks norako's arm that was
injured earlier unfortunately for them
their bag contains a pot cover and
binoculars as weapons somewhere else a
group of students surrounds kazuo trying
to intimidate him they believe that
since he is an outsider they should kill
him first but a guy makes the mistake of
approaching kazuo with a gun in an
instant he gets hold of the gun and
manages to defeat the entire group
without breaking a sweat then he takes
their weapons and makes his way to beat
the others
the pressure of fighting for survival is
too much for some students to take many
of them commit the unthinkable
after that we are introduced to a girl
named mitsuko unlike the others the
situation has turned her into a
cold-blooded murderer she kills a friend
and doesn't even feel a hint of sympathy
for her the next morning shuya and
noriko bump into a friend with an axe
who launches at them shuya makes noriko
run away before fighting the guy himself
the pot cover comes in handy to dodge
the attacks but they soon fall down the
hill in the process the guy hits himself
on the head with the axe shuya looks at
him in regret even though all he did was
defend himself following that he and
noriko run away again this time they are
stopped by a scared guy with a gun he
nervously asks them to stay where they
are too afraid to actually shoot them
taking the opportunity shogo shoots the
guy dead and takes his gun he notices
that shuya and noriko are not trying to
harm anyone and agrees to take them in
for more protection then they see two
girls calling people for help they want
everyone to join them and figure out the
situation together shuya tries to go
help but shogo stops him knowing that
someone else might have heard them hence
the zone is not safe he is proven
correct when kazuo appears and kills the
girls by showering them with bullets he
makes sure to put the horn in their
mouths for the last shot so everyone
would hear the scream and know who to
stay away from in the following scene
mitsuko enters a small warehouse to rest
but sees a girl inside she points her
gun at mexico knowing that she is not
one of the good ones mitsuko gets on her
knees begging for her life but she slyly
tases her before shooting her dad in the
meantime a group of guys is fixing a
laptop they plan to hack the callers and
escape the island together at night
shogo shuya and noriko stay at a tiny
warehouse shogo reveals that when he
played the game before he was with his
friend the two were the only survivors
but one of them had to die for the other
to survive his friend pretended to
betray him and shot his leg so that
shogo would kill her her plan worked but
shogo has never regretted something more
in his life since she died for him he
vowed to play again and find a way to
escape suddenly gunshots are heard from
outside outside kazuo is after a guy who
is wearing a bulletproof vest since he
cannot take the guy down with bullets he
resorts to a sword after decapitating
the poor man he hears a noise from
inside the house that the trio is in he
puts a grenade into the mouth of the
head and throws it inside the house
fortunately the group escapes just
seconds before the explosion shuya runs
outside to distract him but is cornered
in the process kazuo runs out of bullets
which gives him the chance to escape he
jumps into the water just in time to
dodge the attacks the next morning shuya
wakes up in a lighthouse while being
taken care of by a girl named utsumi she
and her group of friends ask him to stay
with them until they reunite with the
rest of the group if they stay together
they may have a higher chance of
escaping one girl from the group was the
friend of the guy who died with an axe
in his head while fighting shuya
yesterday to take revenge she mixes
poison with the food they are about to
give shuya however her plan fails when a
girl eats the food before she can be
stopped the effect of the poison soon
starts to show and she dies vomiting
blood the girls panic and start blaming
each other for poisoning the food a girl
gets her hands on the gun and fires at
all of them the chaos ends with the
death of everyone except for the girl
who poisoned the food shuya knocks on
the door having heard gunshots he is
received by the girl who apologizes to
him and runs to the top of the tower
shuya goes inside and is distraught to
see all of his friends dead he runs
after the surviving girl only to see
that she too has committed the
unthinkable somewhere else norako gets a
dream about having a heart-to-heart
conversation with kitano she had always
respected him unlike the other kids and
sympathizes that he was never respected
at the same time kitano gets a call from
his family who does not care about him
his own daughter calls him insulting him
before hanging up the phone he has
always been treated terribly in his life
which is one of the reasons why he
volunteered to be a part of the battle
royale program later that day shuya
comes looking for noriko and shogo even
though he is severely injured noroco
also wanders around the forest and bumps
into mitsuko who makes fun of her for
hiding behind men she is about to attack
her but runs away after seeing kitano
approach at the same time shuya meets
them but falls unconscious kitano gives
noriko his umbrella and leaves without
saying anything he is kind to her
because she was the only person who was
nice to him during the lowest time of
his life at the same time mitsuko meets
a girl at a warehouse crying over her
friend's death she kills the girl but is
attacked by kazuo seconds later just
when he thinks she is dead she tases him
and counter-attacks with a sickle kazuo
who is already prepared with a
bulletproof vest doesn't die from the
attacks in turn he pushes her away and
finally shoots her dad in the following
scene shogo shuya and noriko are on
their way to the warehouse where the
hackers are staying the hacker is still
trying to gain control over the caller
devices while the others are preparing
explosives with the materials they found
around the island they plan to kill the
military and kitano which is their only
chance to escape after a lot of work the
hacker passes through the control system
and disables the tracking device from
all the callers the group of guys then
load a vehicle outside with explosives
but before they can move kazuo arrives
and ambushes all of them in a desperate
attempt to kill kazuo a guy lights up
the explosives and dies in the ensuing
explosion the trio runs out and sees the
dead bodies of the only friends they had
left kazuo is still alive but has lost
vision in both of his eyes because of
the explosion he fires randomly but
manages to get shogo in the shoulder
still shogo attacks kazuwa repeatedly
and eventually kills him following that
the trio goes to the shore where shogo
reveals that he was only pretending to
be their friend because he wanted them
to protect him now that they are the
only ones left killing them would
benefit him the most with that being
said he shoots at the last couple and
wins the game kitano hears the noise and
declares the game is over the soldiers
do not take much time before returning
home leaving kitano alone on the island
the next morning shogo finds him
exercising they go inside where kitano
finds out that shogo's caller is
disabled shuya and noriko come inside
pointing a gun at kitano and revealing
that they're still alive however to
their surprise kitano already seems to
know that he shows them a picture he
painted of the battle where nordico is
the sole survivor because she is his
favorite student he points a gun at them
but is shot dead before he does any harm
as he dies kitano reveals that his gun
was fake and he didn't want to live
anymore following that the survivors
take a boat to mainland japan but since
shogo has lost a lot of blood from the
injury he passes away on the way in the
last scene shuya and noriko are seen
walking around a city determined to lead
a happy life
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching